roxanne
is in tampa florida hey roxanne welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hey thanks for taking my call sure
what's up i
i have been a bit of a financial
disaster my
life and i've just recently decided to
try and get control of it
so i started by reading the the total
money makeover i just finished that book
and um started listening to the show
yesterday wow
so yes so i'm uh really kind of
at a desperation point of needing to get
myself an order but
also kind of not sure what to do
um trying my best to follow along with
the advice in the book
good so what is that what was baby step
one
baby step one was my uh well i i forget
okay that's all right that's all right
you didn't you didn't know you were
gonna get a test when you called in did
you i didn't know there was a quiz
okay baby step one is quickly get a
thousand dollars as a starter emergency
fund does that sound familiar and that's
what i was going to say but i was unsure
of myself that's okay you're okay um
and i do have that and um i
have actually run into a kind of a
financial
up because i worked an extra summer job
and so i
ended up with about thousand dollars
that can put towards something do you
remember during the book that we said
anything above a thousand goes on your
baby step two where we list your debts
smallest to largest and we're going to
pay them off in that order
how much debt do you have not counting
your home
um i have about
32 000 on my car and i have
about a hundred thousand in student
loans what do you make of here
i make about sixty three thousand okay
your car is too expensive isn't it
yes okay so we need to start working on
getting it sold
and getting you a cheaper car like about
a 5 or a 7 000
i'm really unsure about selling the car
because i don't i'm not gonna get
what i owe on it i know
so what do you owe on it you owe 32
what's it worth
it's worth about 30 or 29 30.
so you i would rather you be three
thousand dollars in debt than thirty two
thousand dollars in debt
yeah go borrow the three thousand at the
credit union
use your seven thousand to get you a
seven thousand dollar car
and voila we just got rid of thirty
thousand dollars worth of debt just like
that
okay you don't sound convinced
yeah i i just don't know what i'll get
for a seven thousand dollar car
but yeah you know i'm uh
you'll get 30 000 worth of less debt you
have a car that owns you
yeah this car is ridiculous
in your financial situation yeah it's
ridiculous
and so you what you've got to do is you
do you have uh how old are you
42. you have family in the area
no okay so what you do do you have
anybody that you know that's a mechanic
um i could find someone yeah yeah ask
around with your friends who's a good
mechanic
have them check out the car and have
them make some suggestions of the type
of car
that'll get you the most use when seven
thousand dollar car we're not buying a
dream car we're buying a car that is
solid transportation and that's all
right
nothing fancy and by the way it's not
forever it's till you get your mess
cleaned up
roxanne how much is your car payment a
month
it's 453 yeah so imagine when you get
that back
what dave just gave you was 453 back
in your budget and now you're putting
that towards
your debt snowball and it's going to
feel a lot better that car may not be
something you're super proud of but
you're going to feel better driving the
7 000
car or i would challenge you to look at
a 5 000
car anywhere in there but then we've got
to get after the rest of those student
loans
and we're going to put you on a budget
and help you do all of that
so here's what's happened okay
you have never in your 40 years of life
addressed the whole subject of money it
has always happened to you
you've never happened to it there's no
shame in that
but my point is is that you are a brand
new toddler barely taking your first
steps
learning to walk and you know
i got grand babies that are toddlers and
when they take those first few steps
they ain't real stable they don't feel
real confident
and that's where you are right now you
don't feel confident doing this
i've been teaching people to do this for
30 years and i've been doing it
longer than you've been alive so it's
my confidence and competence on it is
like automatically i can instantly say
get rid of the car get your seven
thousand dollar car get on a budget and
get an attack mode because i can see how
you can do that mathematically
but in your mind it's so new to you it's
hard for you to ingest that does that
make sense
yes sir and so it's okay that it's a
little shocking and weird to you and you
feel a little off balance
because you've been doing it so poorly
for so long
that to learn to do it right is very
difficult
and you're gonna be great at it you've
just never bothered before and you're
gonna do great
i'm so proud of you
well thank you yeah and do you know what
ramsay plus is
no not yet okay it's a it's a
subscription thing that we have
where you get access to financial peace
university and you go through a nine
week class on how to handle money
it's way down deep into what the total
money makeover teaches and there's a
budgeting
software in there called every dollar a
budgeting app called
every dollar that helps you do that and
there's groups in there to support you
and there's coaches in there to support
you
and there's a tracking app to track your
progress and cheer you on
called the baby steps tracker app as you
work up those baby steps
okay and uh so what we're going to do
since you're brand new at walking
is we're going to put you in the world's
best
program for walking and we're going to
walk
with you and show you how to do it it's
called ramsey plus and i'm going to pay
for it for a year for you okay
oh my goodness and if i do that and i
give it to you
i want you to call me back and yell i'm
debt free someday soon okay
i will all right you hold on kelly i'll
pick up and we'll get you signed up for
this
it is uh it's you know the the hardest
part of transformation
is the first steps oh anything
anything you want to do it because
you're so
unsure you have no confidence you have
no stability
tons of fear too you could hear it what
am i gonna do about a car
it's a legitimate fear yeah and as you
walked her through it
now she's soaking on that she's going
okay all right
okay it's a whole new paradigm
you just shifted it it's the same thing
when you're talking about careers
it's a brand new thing to think about
leaving this job after 10 years
that's a it's a scary thing and it
should be scary because you can't see it
so what you have to do is keep working
till you can see it
when you can see it you can achieve it